I look like what's the the character's
name in Game of Thrones that is like the
Quran daughter she sleeps with the night
king dragons your cars the bear oh good
answer Leo DiCaprio yeah Leonardo that's
who I was thinking oh okay what I was
talking about Lancel Lannister right oh
he's sure
oh we were close so I'm ready to [ __ ]
throw hands wait why are there
basketball hoops in here wait if they're
always been basketball hoops in here you
can throw your boots yeah oh you can
throw infinite boots at the start
wow you really can that is infinite
boots
I made it hope I made a baskets I made
so many baskets because we have infinite
boots look like naked Norman Reedus kind
of I'm so glad you have jiggle physics
that is exactly scheme needed come on
come on
I'm stirring up some trouble it's such a
that's such an inappropriately calm
gestures like guys this room is safe the
other rooms will kill you this way come
along okay should we explain it it's
fine Oh God are you kidding me oh you
are joking me mark are you in some kind
of trouble in there no I'm fine man I
just go oh yeah it's real smoky it's
really smoky yeah yeah what's this brick
watch this trick of a classic the
classic look at that dumbass mark come
on
yeah fooling around come on man yeah
come on okay come on all right well
thanks guys take this one
well you gonna throw a boot or you just
gonna oh man you're going in there
there's just a mine on the ground be
careful
oh that's what that is Oh God you seem
fine the whole room I was just intrigued
about what was going on in there you
know red flashing light he was the type
of person who went playing in traffic as
a kid weren't you I survived so why is
she crow boring away and suck my boot
Hey how'd that oh nice - yeah there you
go that really pissed her off
wait the landmine went off oh you didn't
even watch them blow up Hey look a
crowbar I can't I can't grab this this
crowbar right here I can't I gotta mark
what you're doing
hey silly pants scooch over a little bit
you should pick up the extra shoe I have
I have two shoes you only have two home
very short of two shoes yeah come on
silly Billy okay there's people you goof
you goofed pants this is my one right Oh
God okay well we're going in together
great oh let's do the next one let's do
the next one quickly there's a camera in
the middle take a picture of our
immediate death here I'm gonna kill this
guy don't go over there close to it we
got to just watch that whole situation
just evaporate don't think what an idiot
stool exploration going I'm really
killing it guys I am destroying it I am
I've got it you come come fine come to
me what is that oh I don't like that
sound wait dude don't defeat oh it's
just a countable game okay well pretty
safe I'm in here now Bob Bob I'm in here
hello I just feel safe yeah you guys
need to stop being such big baby
and start charging the way because I'm
happy I'm at the exit I think we should
get here to get out of here real quick
yeah yeah I don't like that one eh oh
it's gross Oh
ghosts oh you guys are just
intentionally I found a room that
revived mark oh my oh god a ghost I'm
here you hate to see it Oh Bob Bob don't
even look at it don't even look at it
guys look at me oh okay so lose my dude
right there
giant paper clips I really accidentally
revived you and you killed yourself in
less than 10 seconds no I killed myself
that was not me killing myself actual
self who walked into the room who's
who's I listened what are the odds that
I would walk into two rooms that would
kill me around pretty good
you have boots you could have thrown one
those are the only two death rooms we
have found since we started oh there's a
penny wise balloon gift gift
absolutely get the gift ah
that was not a gift yeah I am I may have
known that was going to happen what does
the right on the door mean me just
locked that's the edge of the map if you
look in the lower left uh
correctamundo my dude mm-hmm I would
have been able to tell you that if I was
in there Bob you know I probably I were
any sort of friend but I'd probably just
say that eyes and ears you want to kill
another person I really do I just picked
up a shoe and I'm ready to live out my
dream Oh
oh wait I want to go in the hole though
yeah that's the hole
my skirt front exit too new for oh come
come in the hole bro I just wanna I just
wanna see what happens no God pick up a
shoe mark I know you're new here every
moment of this playthrough marks good
through kill mark okay okay how do you
survive that I'll never know wait why
was i running shift is walk mark travel
theme wait guys guys wait guys guys hold
on this room was really weird sir
excuse me is he laughing I think he's
laughing I think we should go in here I
think this is a winner
are you okay yeah he's fixing the shark
guys right right is he taking the
placenta from the shark yeah I think so
oh god don't touch the shark I feel bad
for the shark honestly what if I throw
my boots that the shark is that
acceptable
I already did it didn't do anything yes
wait hey toss boots paws boy you want
Silas that and - yeah band egg yourself
I thought you're a gamer he was going to
do a rock you want some it was
definitely my forearm that needed that
you want some of that
yeah your eyes are crossed right yeah
you want so that how do you keep your
eyes in one place if you hold alt R and
F for all at the same time
all right you just want what's up bro
what's the sharks would walk mark how
are you now this number of shark rooms
we just don't know man this is a weird
game or play I'm not dead see me
haha you were supposed to go in that one
that was for you you shut your mouth oh
wow
since the river Styx yeah it's a river
something don't touch the saw blades on
the ground saltwater dog okay baby
ouch alright big dead you got it big
dead
yeah okay don't waste your shoes it's
just an ice room with a big thing though
seasons okay we're fine we're fine it's
a it's a nice room seems fine to me who
are you doing lady I wasted my shoes
what a man leave me my goodness
nah-nah-nah those mines only affect that
one person he hey whoa there are people
living in here hey bud how are you doing
yeah it's gonna kill them some comedic
way what if I throw my booty you want
some of that oh you want some of that
yeah sure on a hole I don't make it into
the okay
how do I use my baton never mind
I've got this shut up let me do my thing
yeah the fire definitely hurt your
forearm most of all don't question
where's the many ways I like the wobb
wobb room you guys hear this dubstep
room over here yeah man I want to go
this way this is go this way Oh
yeah good oh yeah oh yeah look at that
what look at that I was like dude just
go scare didn't you get these banded oh
god it hurts what's happening what is he
I hear click I hear a clicky clicky
clicky clicky arm in the other room that
just activated for some reason why hey
you guys want to do a bet this room yes
sure whatever welcome okay face me okay
well yes don't open one of the doors
nobody open any doors okay
shoes once our friend is dead I call I
call dibs on shoe there was you want an
already dead person over here that you
could have totes had but that's fine
alright look you didn't drop a shoe okay
look at this look at this we took it
over skeleton no make a new skeleton I
will join you one bandages
you don't have one bandages ok ok ok
everybody has to put something of value
in the pot you got something bout you
you got somebody well I don't have
anything your boots throw one of your
boots in there one of your boots
Jesus staring everyone's in everyone's
bought in currency though you have to
pick a door and you have to walk through
it no questions asked
survivor split the loot ok let's go I'll
go this one this one right away you
fools you fool I'm actually totally fine
oh dear there's a guy inside mine who's
dead now what is happening in yours
doctor arms oh well what are the what
are the odds of that oh that's pretty
good man I was hoping that mark would
die
why do you hope that I would die
whatever man oh god I'm an idiot
no no you sounded good I found it you're
not idiot I found it ok but Bob said Bob
yeah I'm coming I'm coming I'm oh boy
what hang on I'll wait for you guys I
need to be right back
I'll catch you drop all right fine
oh god damn oh my god are you glitched
no yeah but my head you were still just
going hi Bob Bob he's he's side-eyeing
me hmm oh hey he's like one of those
paintings that follows you no matter
where you go
ya hear someone asking for help sir
oh that's not a good that those are
missiles those are some nukes dude can I
kill no oh jesus oh Jesus I threw a boot
in and now something's happening yeah I
don't know if that's a good thing
everyone's still alive yeah Omo
Oh Oh daddy's a bad room oh wow we found
a friend who was smacking missiles and
we were like that's a bad idea and then
he died yeah yeah he sounds like he's
having a bad time but he seems fine he
was hitting it with a like a ho all
those missiles are now doing a thing oh
my beautifully sculpted ass well your
ring you're right your toss face alright
my sphincter right in your toss hole
wait are you taller than me wait a
minute a my room my wicked order are you
at all monsters you're just wearing a
week to try and be taught oh no no I'm
already mark what is this eyeballs are
in the center of the chest Madhu don't
that's not how my eyes are down here
thank you
oh no it's another one why are you like
this
yeah why are they oh dear oh geez oh
Jesus oh my god he got straight bopped
wait wait okay oh god no don't close
whoa wait for you to do the heart the
heavy lifting here okay living briefcase
briefcase that's ready to kill us
where's this Harry Potter room or
something muggle nonsense beetle things
I don't think this model okay I don't
think any of this is smart okay
oh sweet Lord Jesus guys with your
claims I'm about 24 health I near here
bandages may very well this is dangerous
room well there goes my shoe I got this
I got this is that a crocodile yeah
don't worry about a spray childen
alligator actually but whatever you
don't can I don't even know what the
difference between those is oh did you
throw a boot already are we safe in this
one well wait boot boot I just threw
hood in there oh jesus oh jesus oh Jesus
now it really zaps you I'm gonna check
this other door on the other side just
in case it's like a corner room if you
don't have a lot of health that's really
not what you want
Oh circle back to another one of the
rooms we were in already shy DT Oh God
that was quite the squish that was very
squishy don't go in that room oh god
mark you were in a bad room look look
look it's fine it's fine it's fine I'm
just trying to make my way to make sure
these don't contain the exit because it
could be anywhere and you know how it is
how many floors we have to go through
five okay here goes my shoes going off
our own is the way to be I think this is
a winning strategy
yeah but Bob you seem to be having a way
easier time to Americans is just fine
homes empty rooms and rooms I don't know
what you're talking about
Oh key all right literally there's not a
thing in this room that even wants that
is some straight day I am good oh wait
but look I fight to revive you what
you're gonna you're gonna give credit
since I revived you it's just us boy it
was a revised so I'm just gonna go with
the fact that everybody's still trying
to come your way yeah books in this
really don't saw so pissed off about it
oh yes oh is that room
oh that is not safe all right you guys
are on my for now right so I should yeah
whoa guys it's all pads Oh death becomes
me please no sorry yeah are you gonna
die down there
don't wait come this way wait are you
this are you dying over there's beneath
these beneath us
oh why oh god don't go there you all
right I had I had boots that I didn't
use Oh
oh hey what's up where were you
you found it you've run a revive room so
I respond here well we're know that you
get to the new floor Ivers might revive
again thanks guys
hey you're welcome this was a plan and
we planned we were just letting you
experiment that of shoe no he walked
right through on my screen oh don't oh
blower it's not how is it blowing in
both directions that doesn't even make
sense
look that's not how physics blower I
heard it right after I said it Wow we'll
get you right back it'll be uh no time
to stop I'm not even fire coming oh oh
don't kill me don't kill me
hey I'm a nice boy gamers oh I was gonna
be safer than that hey hey hey
there's an extra shoe in there probably
now so that's something wait yeah get
that thank God in the chest that's where
you get yes if any one of us to explain
that to our friend who said oh yeah I
had died with so many bandages on me
because I didn't say lab him and never
told her team manages because I was just
a crush anyway oh no I would want to do
that well I guess you're going back in
there this one's not so bad I don't want
to I don't want to like make you nervous
or anything but this is entirely rides
on you and if you fail in any capacity
oh oh it's gonna chop yeah we all fail
this okay straight left we use your shoe
I don't know just use your shoe there
brother
no make fun of me you guys use your shoe
to here that's kind of a book and I'd
been on whatever just gonna bail on your
shoe you're gonna bail your shoe look at
that room okay okay okay oh god no no
there's no way the best of us from the
final exit I would hate to be left
behind
Oh earned that and I got a green common
Krait for my efforts look at we're
dancing now together that's the song I
got ass more of 177 what does that mean
here 177 better than anyone else who
didn't make it out of this place alive I
like those odds but I
will I get an irate you know why clothes
an excellent job okay let's not let's
not be too hard on each other or
ourselves
everybody who made it out I love you
I got a 253 in a blue uncommon crate you
died how to get anything I am way better
than you guys
[Music]